the stock market closed down again
yesterday after reports that the White
House is considering new tariffs on
Chinese goods both the Dow Jones and the
S&P 500 have lost their gains for the
year but a recent CBS News poll found
that 7 and 10 Americans believe the
economy is in pretty good shape
42 percent believe it's improving the
new book trump anomic s-- inside the
america first plan to revive our economy
looks at the administration's policy
making in economics co-authors Stephen
Moore is here he's a visiting fellow at
the Heritage Foundation he has advised
President Trump on taxes and other
issues and he joins us at the table to
discuss welcome to you Stephen my good
morning time so impressed Gail you
actually read the let's start with this
because you said during your first
meeting with Donald Trump he wanted to
talk taxes he said he wanted his tax
cuts to be bigger and more beautiful
than regular tax cut those were his
words so you guys knew that you said you
had to have a plan that was politically
bulletproof because people on both sides
regarded him as a pariah
yeah so what did you do with that well
first of all that that's absolutely true
remember at that time that was backward
and around January of 2016 Democrats
didn't like Donald Trump very much but
the Republicans I got very much either
they viewed him as a threat to the party
and and we met with Donald Trump in his
office at Trump Tower I know you've been
there to meet with them and he was you
know one of the most interesting things
was I went into that room I knew 14 of
the other 15 Republicans running for
president the only one I had never met
was trauma and I had a very negative
impression of him but he was fresh in a
media Hall yeah I thought his run for
the presidency was a publicity stunt
frankly and went into the room and just
he could not have been more gracious you
know more attentive and interested in
policy savvy and we did put this tax
plan together for him and laugher who's
the co-author of the book of course was
the architect of the Reagan tax cut and
so it was a it was a meeting that really
sort of changed the direction of the
country because we did put that plan
together and we got it passed and it was
a big deal so let's talk about the
current state of the economy do you
think that voters that the American
people are losing faith in trim
phenomics losing faith yeah no no I
think this is the this is such an
amazing economy and we've when
took over it was the economy was growing
at barely one-and-a-half percent an hour
you know we've seen two straight
quarters of tremendous growth in fact I
saw the president at the Rose Garden a
couple weeks ago and I said to him you
know mr. president this is working
better than we even thought it would and
he kind of smiled and said you ain't
seen nothing yet but no we're really
impressed I mean we've said today we
have nor seven million more jobs that we
have workers to fill them we've got the
lowest unemployment rate ever and I'm
worried about the stock market yes well
and the latest GDP to report talked
about tariffs essentially dragging down
growth do you know that's a great point
that well you know sometimes he doesn't
when he asked laugher and I to to work
with the man Larry Kudlow by the way we
worked as a team as you know Larry's now
that economist for Trump you know we
said well you know Donald we can't work
for you because we're for free trade and
you're a trade protectionist and I
remember he got very angry at that he
said I am NOT a trade protectionist he
said I I believe in international
commerce and and international trade he
said but we've got to have a better deal
you know we've got to get tough with
some of these companies that's even we
just won't quit one quick one I actually
came around a certain to some extent to
his way of thinking I started looking at
the evidence and Trump was right we had
lower tariffs than a lot of these other
countries that we have trade deals with
and it wasn't a level playing field and
I think ultimately what he wants to get
to is a level playing field let me ask
you talk about growth but the last
growth numbers were goosed a lot by
spending defense spending is up four
points that's not the better the
taxpayer so when you're juicing spending
that's you're just doing it like the
devil yeah I don't like the government
spending and I think that's the biggest
problem with the Republicans right now
is they're spending way too much money
and you're right that was the defense
spending was a big component but look
consumer spending was up a lot in the
last quarter but the quarter before that
business spending was up now what's
interesting about the consumer spending
numbers because you know what the
Democrats are saying is this just as a
tax cut for the rich people and every
meeting I had with Trump on this he
always said I want to make sure this
goes to middle-class workers Trump does
the people always ask me what does he
really care about I think he cares about
those workers in eure Pennsylvania and
put place like Canton Ohio a place in
Rockford all those kind of working-class
Americans who took frankly who've always
voted Democrat
took a gamble with Trump yeah but
they're not sending the tax cut is
unpopular revenues are up and not up
what they would have bet the economist
popular though I mean this gives them
popular because GDP is up because of
spending not because well no no that's a
little bit of a look it's clear that see
government spending is part of it but
the private sector economy is growing
pretty quickly
okay debate could I just say something
about Stephen I was in the green room
and I said I grew up in Turkey and he
said what's your ethnicity no one has
ever asked me that yes you do but I
didn't know if one of your parents was
Turkish I just it threw me because no
one's ever asked me what's your
ethnicity oh I am economists would ask
[Laughter]
anomic is on sale today